kendall if you're looking to make this
year make this the year
oh see you tyler focus on improving your
body blue point medical spa can help
mercedes introduces us to two of the
services that they offer
to help you lose weight and tone your
way through 2021 take a look
[Music]
you can make 2021 the year that you
finally meet some of those goals
like losing some of that extra fat you
may have put on maybe you want to tone
up and we're at blue point medical spa
i have jennifer and melissa here to show
us how we can do that with some really
innovative
new methods what is this method here
that we have for fat reduction
well this is called the vanquish and the
vanquish
helps to reduce fat now how does that do
this this looks like the machine is kind
of going over the body and it's it's all
encompassing it's not just one specific
area it's got your whole
stomach area exactly that's one thing
great about
the vanquish is that when we're using
the treatment
it's using the it's doing the flank and
the stomach area
so what it does it basically takes
radiofrequency or
it's basically heat and it hovers over
the area
and it goes to about 120 degrees and
what it does it takes that fat cell
and it basically like dissolves it
that's fantastic because i've seen other
fat reduction machines before that like
pinch you and it's painful but
she's just laying there enjoying the
treatment she's very comfortable
she can just take a nap and it's not
affecting you know any of her
organs it's just basically like a nice
warm massage
how many treatments usually does it take
to see some results on something like
this
well we recommend four treatments
and you do it once a week now what kind
of results have you seen with something
like this
what i've seen with our clients is about
two to two and a half
inches in diameter loss now we want to
do
some sculpting some toning and tell us
about this machine
well this machine is called m-sculpt and
what it does
it basically takes a high intensity
electromagnetic
and it focuses on the areas of the
muscle and you can hear
it's like a pulsing sound yes so which
in essence is she doing like
thousands and thousands of sit-ups right
now but just by laying there
well basically it's just taking the
electromagnetic
pulses and it's doing about 20 000
pulses in 30 minutes so you could come
in on your lunch break
and have basically a workout in 30
minutes
as you can see we are all wearing masks
here and blue point medical spa really
takes precautions when it comes to
protecting customers
who come in during these coveted times
tell everyone what you guys do
well we have our office sprayed three
times a week
and then we wipe all surfaces down in
between each client
very clean very safe environment to get
these procedures done
now let's talk about the price of these
procedures you guys what
really recommend that you get a series
of four for each one the m sculpt and
the vanquish
how much does each package cost well
each package
for the m sculpt is four for two
thousand
and then for the vanquish it's four for
a thousand
great way to kick off the new year toned
and losing some fat at blue point
medical spa
that is blue point medical spa and it is
located at 3320 north buffalo drive you
can call them at 702-307-3330
or just find them online at
bluepointmedicalspa.com
make sure you take advantage of their
promotion as well if you're interested
get four vanquish treatments for one
thousand dollars
and four of their m skull treatments for
two thousand
all right we'll be right back on las
vegas